sono un ingegnere un ricercatore e mi
sono trovato a lavorare in un campo che
è diventato ultimamente piuttosto
interessante inventato interessante ne
parlano tutti di fatto per cui è stato
bello trovarci si mezzo senza averlo
voluto di fatto uno segue le proprie
passioni fino a quando e bambino inizia
a programmare i primi computer quando a
11 anni e poi un bel giorno scopre che
le cose che gli piacciono fare in realtà
sono diventate anche popolari sono
diventate popolari perché si pensa che
queste tecnologie potranno cambiare il
mondo essere rivoluzionaria e come
diceva gli yogi berra
se c'è una biforcazione prendi la che
tradotto per quello che invece facciamo
noi vuol dire che queste tecnologie
prima o poi ci arrivano addosso non
importa quello che facciamo e quindi
tanto vale cogliere l'occasione cogliere
l'occasione anche per l'italia di essere
partecipi di essere dei giocatori di
questa partita piuttosto che subirla
come è successo con tante altre
tecnologie più o meno recenti che poi
sono realtà realizzate magari in altri
paesi non che io mi occupi di auto ma ci
sono state altre tecnologie che hanno
cambiato il mondo
l'automobile una di queste un'altra
piuttosto interessante
sono stati la telefonia cellulare e
telefoni cellulari e la capacità di
comunicare non ho scelto a caso queste
due esempi perché secondo me uno
rappresenta l'esempio della mobilità
quindi della capacità di muovere
qualcosa nel mondo
l'altro rappresenta la capacità invece
di avere un oggetto intelligente non per
niente si chiamano smart phone gli
ultimi usciti quindi la capacità di fare
computazione su un dispositivo tutto
sommato piccolo
ebbene quello che faccio in qualche modo
coglie alcuni di questi due aspetti e li
mette insieme quindi vorremmo fare degli
oggetti che sono allo stesso tempo
capaci di muoversi nel mondo e di essere
anche mediamente intelligenti
l'altro aspetto interessante di queste
due tecnologie che hanno impiegato tempi
molto diversi a raggiungere il 90 per
cento
diciamo delle case il cellulare in soli
15 anni
l'automobile ce ne ha messi ben di più è
uno di quei grafici che vedete li 70
anni più o meno 75 anni e hanno però
anche due aspetti diversi dal punto di
vista dell'hardware
l'automobile è una cosa molto pesante
quindi anche una complessità di
realizzazione molto diversa di quella di
un dispositivo portatile
ebbene alla robotica è qualcosa che sta
in mezzo
ancora non sappiamo quanto ci metterà
perché nelle case di fatto non è
arrivata il una persona non del tutto
sconosciuta amiri gates
qualche tempo fa nel 2008 scommetteva
sul fatto che la prossima rivoluzione
tecnologica sarà esattamente la robotica
ma la robotica di un tipo particolare
non quella industriale che esiste già ma
quella che avremo con la quale avremo a
che fare tutti i giorni
quella che ci raggiungerà in casa e bill
gates diceva anche cose simpatiche del
tipo che chi farà questo tipo di
tecnologia di fatto realizzare a
qualcosa molto più grande di microsoft
che non è la cosa diciamo la ditta la
company più grande che esista però
sicuramente un bel colosso il una
visione di questo futuro sicuramente
arriva dalla fantascienza questo è un
sono immagini traccia un film abbastanza
recente che però rappresentano bene
quello che vorremmo fare quindi delle
macchine al servizio dell'uomo che
interagiscono con l'uomo nella vita di
tutti i giorni quindi qualche modo i
compagni robotizzati del futuro
invece di portarci dietro lo smartphone
ci porteremo dietro un oggetto che fa
qualcosa anche di più a delle mani per
esempio col quale può interagire in
maniera fisica con il mondo che lo
circonda
lo smartphone per quanto insistiamo il
caffè ancora non solo porta il questa
tecnologia invece potrebbe farlo questa
è la mia personale ricetta su cosa ci
servirebbero cosa dovremmo fare adesso
per arrivarci una sicuramente la ricerca
è un altro e trovare quelle che sono le
applicazioni
il mercato di questi oggetti non esiste
e quindi senza un'applicazione
fondamentale quell'applicazione chiave
non ci si arriva
l'altro aspetto importante che in realtà
la tecnologia non è neanche matura per
quanto si vedano delle cose in giro per
i laboratori di ricerca
ancora non sono pronte a uscire dal
laboratorio e trasferirsi nella vita
reale per la ricerca qualcosa stiamo
facendo anche in italia io lavoro in un
posto che si chiama istituto italiano di
tecnologia che è un
diciamo una serie di laboratori il cui
quartier generale si trova a genova che
ha investito tanto in robotica circa un
terzo delle persone che formano questo
istituto lavorano in robotica l'istituto
a 1.500 persone
fate un po voi i conti sapete quanti
ricercatori ci sono in questo momento
ingegneri ricercatori che lavorano nel
campo della robotica con applicazioni
diverse
io mi occupo di un aspetto diciamo
particolare della robotica che quello
della robotica interattiva quindi
realizzare le macchine che poi possono
effettivamente interagire con l'uomo
la cosa interessante in questo istituto
che per la prima volta forse in italia è
riuscito a fare delle cose belle del
tipo portare diciamo dei ricercatori
stranieri a lavorare da noi e non come
succede di solito far andar via gli
italiani è riuscito a portare indietro
degli italiani che lavoravano all'estero
invece a genova ed è riuscito in pochi
anni a raggiungere una qualità dei
risultati misurata secondo gli indici
tipici della ricerca quindi le
pubblicazioni quanto sono citate che ci
colloca di fatto vicino a tutti gli
altri istituti tecnologia mondiali
quindi vicino alle mai ti è vicino al al
freno fair vicino a giorgia tech e così
via vicino a stanford quindi di fatto
siamo tanto bravi quanto gli altri non
abbiamo nulla da invidiare e questo
l'abbiamo fatto però con un istituto che
è nato solo nel
2003 in cui diciamo laboratori primo
laboratorio è diventato attivo nel 2006
quindi confrontato con le mitiche alla
stessa età dell'italia quindi più di 150
anni questo per dire che si possono fare
delle cose mettendo dei fondi nella
ricerca si può ottenere dei risultati si
possono ottenere dei risultati
il piano di ricerca del nostro istituto
prevede di ispirarci alla natura quello
che ha fatto la natura e in particolare
su un certo aspetto cercare di copiare
l'uomo per ottenere delle macchine che
siano più simili all'uomo
da un certo punto di vista e ne
riproducono alcune delle capacità questo
video vi fa vedere alcune delle cose che
abbiamo fatto e questa in particolare
quella del lavoro cui diciamo il robot
che ho progettato nel quale mi sono
occupato con i miei colleghi per i circa
dieci anni di vita dell'istituto
umanoide come vedete è una macchina è
stata progettata per la ricerca quindi
se domani dovessimo decidere cosa fa
questo robot ancora non fa nulla di
utile
quello che però può fare è essere una
piattaforma per tanti ricercatori per
avere per provare i propri metodi i
propri algoritmi e la propria ricerca su
una piattaforma che è standardizzata in
questo video si vede di fatto un po di
interazione con l'uomo con gli oggetti
il robot alle telecamere per vedere
microfoni per sentire ai sensori tattili
che riproducono la sensazione del tatto
come nella pelle
tutte queste cose sono messe insieme in
una macchina con la quale si può parlare
la macchina vede riconoscere gli oggetti
li identifica gli si possono insegnare
cose nuove ea una capacità di apprendere
di un certo tipo non è in grado di
apprendere qualunque cosa però ad
esempio di sconsigliare a prendere uno
e poi lui lo prende correttamente liszt
può insegnare a riconoscere qualcosa che
non ha mai visto prima
elaborando le immagini lo fa in maniera
corretta ed è progettata proprio per
l'interazione con l'essere umano si vede
in questo video esperimenti che lo dove
il robot cammina dove proviamo a tenerlo
in equilibrio
tutte cose che un giorno consentiranno a
questo questa tecnologia di ricevere
degli ordini da una persona e di portare
a compimento certo certo tasker di dove
questo tasker sarà magari quello di
andare a prendere qualcosa per noi
immaginate assistere persone che hanno
molto mobilità ridotta a trovare le cose
per noi
costruire un insieme di possibilità che
daranno alla macchina la capacità di
essere veramente d'aiuto il qualche
soddisfazione ce la siamo tolta lungo la
strada in un articolo del 2012 il
financial times citava la ridente
economia tedesca e lungo la strada però
ha messo un robot italiano per
rappresentare la macchina miracolosa
della dell'economia tedesca una bella
soddisfazione perché poi insomma perché
mettere il robot italiano
un'altra cosa che è successa che tanti
nostri colleghi hanno trovato quello che
abbiamo fatto interessante è poi pallini
nelle mappe rappresentano dei posti dove
c'è una copia identica del nostro robot
c'e neppure uno in giappone che se
pensate che la patria della robotica
umanoide dove è nata la robotica
umanoide già negli anni 70 all'ora stata
la bella soddisfazione che qualcuno
all'università di osaka ci abbia chiesto
di fatto il nostro robot per fare le
loro ricerche
devo dire però che non è tutto già fatto
soprattutto se adesso dovessimo andare a
guardare quello che può fare il robot
rispetto a quello che ci aspettiamo che
faccia c'è ancora della strada da fare
quindi in realtà di queste applicazioni
concrete non ce l'abbiamo ancora ci sono
altri problemi la meccatronica non è
così avanzata da consentirci di fare
veramente un prodotto ci vogliono sei
mesi per fare un robot costa tantissimo
ed è pure non tanto intelligente e
quindi alla fine non è un bell'oggetto
da comprare non sia assolutamente
conveniente
noi ci aspettiamo però che la ricerca di
fatto questi quattro settori che vi
indico qua possa portare dei frutti in
tempi non lunghissimi
ci vorranno di nuovi materiali per fare
il corpo del robot perché
sfortunatamente per come è fatto adesso
i robot si rompe
per quanto si possa pensare che i robot
siano molto forti in realtà non è
neanche molto forte una persona è molto
più forte del robot ci vorrà
dell'intelligenza artificiale avanzata
perché quella che abbiamo adesso di
nuovo non è sufficiente a fare le cose
che vi ho descritto il robot ancora il
caffè non ce lo porta nonostante i
nostri dieci anni di ricerca ci sarà
magari un intelligenza in rete e questa
magari sembra essere più vicina e c'è da
risolvere un problema energetico perché
per come è fatto adesso alla macchina
consuma troppo e non abbiamo delle
batterie sufficienti per farla
funzionare per i tempi tipici di un
elettrodomestico
questa è una visione del futuro e questo
è un futuro sul quale stiamo lavorando
quello che vede dietro è una
rappresentazione grafica del prossimo
nostro progetto
un robot che costerà poco questa volta
che sarà fatto principalmente a nuovi
materiali da plastiche che sperabilmente
sarà più vicino all utilizzatore
piuttosto che al ricercatore per
concludere volevo lasciarvi con una
frase che trovo interessante e di isaac
asimov dal libro ai robot e c'è uno
scambio di battute tra due persone una
chiede quanti anni ha
l'altra dice 32 e la risposta della
prima persona allora lei non può
ricordare com'era il mondo senza e robot
non è questo ricorda molto mio figlio
che per esempio non conosce la musica
che se non digitale la videocassetta non
sa cosa sia bene io spero e immagino che
un giorno tra qualche anno
esisteranno delle persone che non hanno
mai conosciuto un mondo senza i robot